what does the pdb the president's daily
brief look like how long is it what does
it contain
so first of all it looks like the most
expensive book report you can ever
imagine it's got its own binder it's all
very high end it feels important it
looks important it's not like a cheap
trapper keeper
it's somewhere between i would give it
probably between 50 and 125 pages a day
it's produced every day around 2 o'clock
in the morning by a dedicated group of
analysts and and each
page is essentially
a short paragraph to a few paragraphs
about a priority happening that affects
national security from around the world
the president rarely gets to the entire
briefing in a day he relies on a briefer
instead to prioritize
what inside the briefing needs to be
shared with the president because some
days the pdb will get briefed in
10 minutes and some days it will be
briefed over the course of two hours it
depends on the president's schedule
how much competition is there for the
first page
and uh so
how much jockeying there is for
attention
for
i imagine for all the different
intelligence agencies
and within the cia there's probably
different groups that are modular and
they're all care about different
nations or different uh
cases and
is there do you understand
how much competition there is for the
attention for the limited attention of
the president you're 100 correct in
how the agency and how
officers and managers of the agency
handle the pdb there's a ton of
competition everybody wants to be the
first on the radar everybody wants to be
on the first page the thing that we're
not baking into the equation is the
president's interests
the president dictates what's on the
first page of his pdb and he will tell
them usually the day before i want to
see this on the first page tomorrow
bring this to me in the beginning i
don't want to hear about what's
happening in mozambique i don't really
care about what's happening in saudi
arabia i want to see one two three and
regardless of whether or not those are
the three biggest things in the world
the president's the executive he's the
one he's the ultimate customer so we do
what the custom what the customer says
that has backfired in the past if you
haven't already started seeing how that
could go wrong
that is backfired in the past but that
is essentially what happens when you
serve in the executive branch you serve
the executive so what's the role the
director of the cia versus the president
what's that dance like so the the
president really leads
the focus of the cia
the president is the commander-in-chief
for the military but the the executive
the president is also the executive for
the entirety of the intelligence
community so he's the the ultimate
customer
if you look at it like a business
the customer the person spending the
money is the president and the director
is the ceo
so if the director doesn't create what
the president wants there's going to be
a new director that's why the director
of cia is a presidential appointed
position sometimes they're extremely
qualified intelligence professionals
sometimes they're just professional
politicians or soldiers that get put
into that seat because the president
trusts them to do what he wants them to
do
another
gaping
area that causes problems but that's
still the way it is
so you think this is a
problematic configuration of the whole
system massive flaw in the system it is
a massive flaw in the system because
if you're essentially appointing a
director to do what you want them to do
then you're assigning a crony and that's
what we define corruption as within the
united states and inside the united
states we say if you pick somebody
outside of merit for any other reason
other than merit then it's cronyism or
it's nepotism
here that's exactly what our structure
is built on all presidential appointees
are appointed on something other than
merit so for an intelligence agency to
be effective it has to
discover the truth and communicate that
truth and maybe if you're appointing the
director of that agency you're not
they're less likely to communicate the
truth to you unless the truth aligns
perfectly with your desired worldview
well not necessarily perfectly because
there are other steps right they have to
be they have to go in front of congress
and they have to have the support of of
multiple legislatures
or legislators but they
they're
the challenge is that the short list of
people who even get the opportunity
aren't a meritorious list it's a short
list based off of who the president is
picking or who the would-be president is
picking now i think we've proven
that an intelligence organization can be
an intelligence organization can be
extremely effective even within the
flawed system yeah the challenge is how
much more effective could we be if we
improved and that's
i think that's the challenge that faces
a lot of the us government i think
that's a challenge that has resulted in
what we see today when it comes to the
decline of american power and american
influence the rise of foreign influence
attack authoritarian powers
and a shrinking u.s economy a growing
chinese economy and it's just
we have questions hard questions we need
to ask ourselves about how we're going
to handle the future what aspect of that
communication between the president and
the cia could be fixed
to help
fix the problems that you're referring
to in terms of the decline of american
power so
when you talk about the president
wanting to prioritize
what the president cares about
that immediately shows a break between
what actually matters to the long-term
success of the united states versus what
happened what benefits the short-term
success of the current president because
any
president
is just a human being and has a very
narrow focus and narrow focus is not a
long-term calculation exactly what's the
maximum amount of years a president can
be president
eight yeah he has to be he or she in the
united states in the united states
according to our current constitution
yeah
but they they're very limited uh in
terms of what they have to prioritize
and then if you look at a four-year
cycle two years of that is essentially
preparing for the next election cycle so
what's only two years of really quality
attention you get from the president
who's the chief executive of all the
intelligence community so the most
important thing to them is not always
the most important thing to the
long-term survival of the united states
you